the best organization in the world and
what is that
proud boy hell yeah
[Music]
one of the most prominent groups to
storm the capital on january 6th was the
proud boys
a right-wing extremist group whose
members describe themselves as western
chauvinists the proud boys are taking
over dc
the wall street journal analyzed
hundreds of videos from the riot
social media posts court filings and
interviewed participants in the events
and experts on extremism
in an effort to piece together the most
complete picture of the proud boy's role
in the events that day
the journal's investigation shows proud
boys coordinating
instigating and leading some of the most
pivotal moments of the rush into the
historic building
that disrupted lawmakers certification
of the presidential election
and resulted in the death of five people
including one police officer
[Music]
about seven proud boys have been
arrested so far for their actions at the
capitol
more than any other right-wing group
there that day
proud boy chairman enrique tario told
the journal the proud boys didn't
coordinate their actions or intend to
storm the capital
and many of the threats that the journal
pointed out were meant as a joke
he also said the proud boys don't
condone violence unless in self-defense
tario wasn't at the capitol that day
because he was arrested days before
and charged with destruction of property
and was banned from the city
[Music]
the proud boys first earned mainstream
attention when president trump didn't
denounce white supremacists and
right-wing militia groups in a september
presidential debate
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
the moment emboldened the group its
leader enrique tario posted a message on
social media shortly after
saying simply standing by sir it has
been widely reported that the group
planned to
attend a rally at the capitol on january
6th to protest election results
joe biggs another leader called for
violence on social media
all right guys you want to see all the
proud boys out here today here we go
everybody cover up on the day of the
event
more than a hundred proud boys from
around the country were there montana
like his channel a proud boy live
streamer named eddie block
extensively filmed the group as they met
and coordinated
i know right block declined to comment i
know exactly
in the morning before a rally near the
white house with president trump
the proud boys meet on the east side of
the capitol
biggs can be seen organizing groups of
proud boys he's equipped with a radio
if you're on the outside making sure
you're looking on the outside of the
perimeter and sneaking up on us
biggs has since been arrested and
charging documents say he aided
abetted and commanded others to
unlawfully enter the capitol
biggs and his attorney did not respond
to multiple requests for comment
milkshake's afraid of me scott a proud
boy known as milkshake can be heard
shouting
but is chastised by others
let's not yell that all right
milkshake
[Laughter]
idiot
scott did not respond to multiple
requests for combat
some individuals who would hours later
participate in the riot
can be seen taking part in the
rendezvous
there's michael porter who identified
himself to the journal as a proud boy
this man whose identity the journal
could not fully confirm in
interviews social media searches and
court documents can be seen with the
group throughout the day
instigating the mob and robert geeswine
who's also with the group throughout the
day
and is wearing patches suggesting
affiliation with proud boys and
right-wing
groups i gotta get one of these
rallied by biggs and another leader
ethan nordin known as rufio
the proud boys coalesce and march on the
capital
nordine declined to comment
two men on a mission with about 500
behind them ready to kick some butt
standing for this country
so the proud boy's coming in at around
12 50 p.m while president trump has
taken the stage at a nearby rally
another live streamer captures the proud
boys approaching the capitol from the
northwest and encountering a small
police presence behind a temporary
barrier
[Music]
biggs huddles with an individual in a
red hat and carrying a flag
[Music]
who just minutes later is the first to
charge the barriers
[Music]
[Applause]
proud boys can be seen in the crowd
porter told the journal that he
participated in a protest not a riot
and that he did not enter the capitol
[Applause]
the few police officers there quickly
fall back
and the proud boys make up a large
portion of the first wave to reach the
base of the capital
[Applause]
proud boys are among those who square
off with capitol police at the base of
the building
[Music]
dominic pizzola a proud boy and military
veteran known as spazzo
is on the front lines with a wire in his
ear
pizzola's attorney told the journal his
client did not coordinate his actions
with anyone and that the radio earpiece
was for listening to music
this man who continues to be seen with
the proud boys appears to be directing
members of the mob
to the left side of the police line
geese wine is nearby
and other leadership also take prominent
places on the front line near the
capitol steps
a protracted battle between rioters and
outnumbered police ensues
and proud boys like pizzola can be seen
throughout key parts of the
confrontation
[Applause]
around 137 geese wine tries to push
through the police barriers
and an hour later rioters try to flank
the police by climbing scaffolding
[Applause]
pizzola takes part in the charge
and geese wine sprays police with an
unidentified substance
geese wine was arrested for assaulting a
federal officer destruction of
government property
entering a restricted area and
disrupting congress
geeswine's attorney declined to comment
at around 212 pizzola breaks a window to
the capitol with a police shield
he and geeshwine are among the first
rioters to enter the building
pizzolo was arrested on january 15th for
unlawful entry destruction of government
property and obstruction of an official
[Music]
[Applause]
proceeding
inside the capitol a crowd of rioters
encounter officer eugene goodman
they follow him up a set of stairs
coming perilously close to the lawmakers
who are just down the hall through the
doorway to the left of goodman
pizzola and geeswine are in the crowd
entering the building close behind is
biggs
[Music]
it's over around the same time at the
base of the building the police line is
breaking apart
and crowds storm more entrances
[Applause]
as larger groups of rioters breach the
building parts of the proud boys
contingent
make it inside
nicholas oaks leader of the hawaii
chapter of the proud boys
was arrested after boasting about
entering the capital on social media
oaks and his attorney declined to
comment
[Applause]
according to the charging documents from
miami proud boy gabrielle garcia
he roamed the capitol calling for nancy
pelosi to quote
come out and play a lawyer for garcia
said that he did not damage property or
commit violence at the capitol
his comments about pelosi were in jest
and he wants nothing to do with the
proud boys
[Music]
since the riot proud boy's leadership
has tried to downplay their role
but the journal's investigation shows
that at every key breach of the
capital's defenses
the proud boys and members of their
contingent are at the forefront of the
mob
and can be seen coordinating and
instigating
authorities have arrested about seven
proud boys so far for their role in the
attack
other proud boys have threatened more
violence jake this is a shot across the
back
next time we come armed porter told the
journal he made this statement as an
individual
not as a representative of the proud
boys proud boy leadership was
unapologetic about the violence in a
live stream after the riots
i've answered reporters uh for the past
week that keep saying
well the proud boys planned this and
this is up and they've told me to
denounce it
listen i'm not going to denounce
anything tario told the journal that his
and bake's comments in this show were
expressing the views of trump supporters
who have felt marginalized by the system
it's only going to get worse and that's
what people don't understand
is the more you push the bear the more
you poke the bear the bear is going to
come back